was ist das denn für mich sehr herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
gerade du bist nun möglich das setting
ich hab in meinem auto
denn heute passiert was besonderes
erinnert euch vielleicht noch an das
video was ich schon mal gemacht habe wo
ich versucht habe meiner schwester in
der switch zu besorgen
das hat sich jetzt geändert denn ich
habe über im kontakt ein internes
bekommen die sich hier in diesem paket
befindet man ja was wir jetzt machen ich
bin jetzt gab noch in köln werde mit dem
auto nach bayern rüberfahren zu meiner
familie und meine schwester und ich mal
mit der richtigen switch überraschen
es gebe
okay wir sind da leute ich glaube ich
weiß jetzt so machen ich wer drinnen die
kamera aufstellen dann mit dem paket
reingehen
ich weiß zwar dass sich überraschend für
sie haben das nicht was es ist und dann
schauen wir mal was passiert jetzt
einmal auspacken würde was ist das denn
[Musik]
was ist denn überhaupt was ist noch drin
mach jetzt zirka 500 euro
doch was ist das grabs linken dafür
erzeugt dabei sagen wir selber mario
kart acht weißt du dich selber lieber
tee ist ein spieler eine halterung die
controller controller von was man es von
der switch nein so komisch runde länger
viel spaß mit den mädchen das mit paket
menschen die ihr team mit ja und rot ja
nicht komplett dumm wären aber coole
exakt was ist denn gedacht dass
überraschung ist es also ein
freizeitpark ich habe gesagt ich kann
eigentlich nur sein ist es entweder
eines coaches zu bekommen sondern von
pferden frühstück vater machte die ferne
schauen das video unten
hier ist das ist die richtige
du kriegst du nicht ausgepackt anstelle
der gibt's resultieren dann schicke ich
wieder zurück leute eine sache möchte
jetzt nur noch sagen und zwar falls das
jetzt irgendwie vielleicht vielleicht so
gewirkt als hätte meine schwester ist
jetzt nicht so mega gefreut rebellen
aber keine ahnung vielleicht wirkt das
so ich habe ja schon mal probiert ihr
innerstes zu besorgen aber keine
bekommen heute hatten wir das wird
endlich geklappt deswegen hat fehlt ein
bisschen schon derart das ist eine suite
werden könnte man doch auch sollte das
video soll überhaupt nicht angeberisch
sein so nach dem motto ich kann das und
das holen ist einfach eine richtig coole
gelegenheit das nintendo gesagt hat
das unterstützen wir und ich wäre ja
froh über die möglichkeit so was machen
zu können dass ich einfach meine
schwester so eine coole überraschung
machen kann und dazu tragen natürlich
zum großen teil auch hierbei in dem ihr
mich irgendwie keiner hast dich findet
aber irgendwo und irgendwann meine
videos zu schauen und mir die chance
gibt euch quasi zu unterhalten nur
dadurch kann auch sowas entstehen
überhaupt für mich und für meine familie
und ich bin ich richtig cool danke dafür
leute noch eine sache eine frage mich
manchmal bekomme ist warum ist eine
schwester die videos wenn ihr gesicht
nicht zeigen das ist ganz einfach ich
mag es konnte mit meiner familie zu
machen also meine familie meine videos
integriert ist nicht mein bruder max ja
sowieso ist sondern auch meine schwester
meine mutter aber ich will eben gerade
bei meiner schwester nicht weil die so
jung ist dass sie erkannt würden wir auf
der straße angesprochen wird und noch
was was sie niemals vergessen dürfte
leute ist das leute im internet echt
gemein sind und davor mit die meine
schwester eben schützen indem ich nicht
ihr gesicht zeigen und das würde hier
glaube ich auch nicht wollen für ihre
geschwister oder familie ja das ist so
meine gedanken zu dem thema ich hoffe
ihr könnt euch wissen wann der kleine
schwester mit freund und wie seit vielen
dank dafür dass ihr das überhaupt
möglich macht dass so was geht in meinem
leben man könnte meinen knall abonnieren
und hier drüben in der folge was es geht
[Musik]